Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new Wandavision doctor strange 2 predictions
video there's so much stuff that they set up
in Wandavision and so much that we already
know about doctor strange 2 so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be doing
videos for all the marvel disney plus series this
year falcon and winter soldier is coming up in a
couple weeks so i'll remind everybody about the
schedule at the end of the video too but careful
for spoilers for all the Wandavision episodes so
far if you haven't seen them so just starting
with number 10 scarlet witch using the darkhold
will be the whole catalyst for the plot leading
into doctor strange 2 and it'll be all about her
chaos magic just going off the rails she wields
power that's very similar to the energy of the
infinity stones so think about how much damage was
done with each of the infinity stones and all the
marble movies and then the infinity gauntlet with
thanos the hulk iron man is a good benchmark for
how much damage wanda can get how crazy things can
get with the multiverse and i'll talk about how
the multiverse gets involved with this they kind
of got into that with the nexus commercial and
wanda being a nexus being so number nine speaking
of multiverse wanda is a nexus being i didn't
really talk about this a ton during my Wandavision
episode 9 finale video because they didn't really
reference it verbally in that final episode they
got into it during episode seven and they didn't
really reference it that much after the fact but
there were some clues about what that means wanda
as a nexus being and how that's connected to
her chaos magic the darkhold and the villain
of doctor strange 2 nexus beings in the comics are
people who exist in every single universe of the
multiverse so no matter where you go around the
multiverse there's always a version of wanda of a
scarlet witch in every reality she always winds
up becoming the scarlet witch as the darkhold
says it's more of a title that wanda gets when she
upgrades herself or is forged as agatha harkness
said some great power like the infinity stones
give her a big power boost kang the conqueror
is another nexus being from the comics that we're
going to see in future marvel phase 4 movies like
ant-man 3 quantum mania he'll be the main villain
of that movie he's being played by jonathan magers
who was in lovecraft country on hbo fantastic
series he's a great actor can't wait to see what
he does with the character but we also might see
some teasers and clues about him during the loki
series just because he's mostly a time travel
villain and loki is a time travel series but
nexus beings as the name implies are focal points
for the entire multiverse and because of that
immense cosmic power flows through them which is
kind of what they're hinting at with the final
boss form scarlet witch and agatha the hardness
flipping out you have no idea what you've done
you're going to need me for what's coming number
eight the darkhold showing up on Wandavision makes
it the definitive mcu version of the darkhold i
know a lot of questions about the agents of shield
version of the darkhold i'll talk about that in
a second but doctor strange will probably take it
into custody from wanda after they come together
in the movie but just turning the timeline given
that agatha harkness had the book since the
1600s per her mother evanor harkness in the
coven putting her on trial they kept referring
to her learning dark magic she wasn't ready for
or hadn't earned the right to attempt so she said
the darkhold for the last couple hundred years and
this also gets into the idea of wanda not totally
being ready to try the more dangerous spells in
the darkhold like you see her learning from it in
that post credit scene that'll also probably lead
to a lot of the villain problems that they have to
fix during the movie you may have seen the actor
who played ghost writer on agents of shield making
funny jokes about the darkhold like i knew i
shouldn't have left it under my bed just terrible
hiding place the way kevin feige talks about it he
said that they like to cherry pick characters and
easter eggs from all the tv shows so right now i'm
just considering the agents of shield version of
the darkhold an alternate universe version like
saying this all happened in an alternate universe
just standard multiverse explainer number seven
there will probably be a big spider-man 3 no way
home crossover scene just bridging the events
of that movie to doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness so you have to remember that spider-man 3
is still knock on wood coming out christmas season
this year in 2021 doctor strange 2 is the next big
marvel movie right after that so think direct tom
holland spider-man cameo seen in doctor strange 2
and probably also a spider-man 3 no way home
post credit scene that just sets up what's
going on with wanda the darkhold her chaos magic
in the main villain of doctor strange 2 the way
they crossed over the doctor strange movie with
thor ragnarok like really big crossover also you
remember doctor strange is one of the main
avengers crossover characters confirmed for
spider-man no way home and number six really
big call back to that big spider-man no way
home trailer from a couple days ago in the teaser
images they released a couple weeks ago spider-man
ned leeds and mj are all seen standing in
what looks like a really run-down version of
the sanctum the pattern on the floorboards looks
exactly the same but there's snow inside the walls
look really crappy like no one has lived there
in years like it reminds you of tobey mcguire's
apartment in the spider-man movies you'll get
your rent for the sanctum when you fix this door
there have been a lot of theories about what's
going on with this like why does it look like
the sanctum has been destroyed the best theories
that i've seen so far are that one it could just
be a result of the five-year time jump after
avengers infinity war dr strange most of the
order of sorcerers were snapped so it's possible
that he and wong and anyone else weren't around to
take care of the sanctum and it fell physically
into disrepair the other theory is that it's
just part of the enchantments on the sanctum
like if a normal person somehow were able to
break in the front door and walk around the
protective enchantments inside the sanctum
prevent regular people from gaining access to
all the powerful magical tomes and artifacts
so for most normal people it just looks like
a regular rundown building on bleecker street
but number five kevin feige already confirmed that
we'd see alternate versions of major characters we
already know in doctor strange 2 like alternate
reality versions because of the multiverse
twist there have been a lot of rumors about
which versions specifically that will be like
alternate versions of captain america iron man
and then there's all the spider-man no way home
spider-verse talk with toby maguire and andrew
garfield i know everybody's still kind of reeling
from all the fan theories about Wandavision
like what does that say if they didn't pay a
lot of those off does that mean that we're not
going to see spider-verse stuff in spider-man 3
i wouldn't look too deep into that there's still a
lot of evidence that there is spider-verse related
stuff in easter eggs happening in spider-man 3.
but it's all still speculation so take it all
with a grain of salt i'm also hoping that they pay
off the deleted scene from avengers infinity war
where doctor strange briefly became a version of
iron man and iron man briefly became a version of
doctor strange they kind of swapped for a second
when iron man and spider-man were saving him from
ebony maw iron man covered doctor strange
in his nano armor when it formed around him
it looked like this with the center being the eye
of agamotto instead of an arc reactor really cool
they even made benedict cumberbatch walk around
on set with that chess piece and everything they
actually filmed this scene and then just
wound up cutting it out of the actual film
and while this was happening as you see him
wearing the cloak of levitation dr strange's
cloak covered iron man and floated him down to
the ground so it was just meant to be a cool
easter egg from the comics like there are versions
of iron man who eventually became the sorcerer's
supreme in the comics but i'm not expecting to
see robert downey jr come back for new scenes
in doctor strange 2 so if they wind up paying off
this deleted scene it would probably just be the
doctor strange part of that like we see alternate
universe versions of doctor strange there's also
a little bit of that happening during the marvel
what if series if you've seen the footage of the
doctor strange episode you see him fighting what
looks like an evil version of himself i will be
doing episode videos for that but those episodes
won't drop until the summer so it's still a ways
off number four because they held off on major
x-men mutants moments from Wandavision with the
whole house of m storyline they'll also probably
use some of those alternate universes and doctor
strange to to reference some of the fox x-men
movies in a bigger way like we have evan peters
quicksilver from the fox x-men films starring
on Wandavision but they did him in a very twisty
way and he wound up being ralph boner a totally
different character so it is kind of a reference
to the fox x-men films but not in the way that
people thought it was referencing those films
but eventually they will start laying track work
for something like secret wars where we see a
ton of alternate universe versions of characters
and also explaining how some of the legacy actors
actors from the fox x-men films coming back and
playing their characters in new marvel projects
they'll have to explain that somehow the
multiverse is the easiest way to do that
there were some mutants easter eggs and references
on Wandavision just not as many as people expected
like that was the whole monica rambeau photon
storyline her dna being mutated by the hex
and you have billy and tommy who were born
with their powers which is the major qualifier
for being a mutant they had that scene in the
finale where they say we didn't train you for this
but you were born into it so that was just
them referencing them as x-men characters
even though technically they're more like young
avengers characters a little bit different but the
same concept mutants the eternals movie is also
going to be another piece of that puzzle too where
you have a very different group of characters
with superpowers that come from a different place
in the mcu just broadening the mythology in a very
cosmic way and helping explain some of the bases
for the x gene and people who will eventually
be born naturally with powers but number three
the main villain of doctor strange 2 will be
tied to wanda's chaos magic pearl this set up
on Wandavision and since in the comics that's
cathone just based on the easter eggs that they
are including on Wandavision i'm saying it's more
likely that's who they're setting up for doctor
strange 2 but given how much they've changed
everything from the comics it's always possible
that marvel changes the cathode character and
just calls him something else or like they do
a version of nightmare but they give him all
of cathone's backstory in the comics marvel as
you've learned recently on wandavision tends to
oversimplify a lot of the technical details from
the comics so just don't expect the main villain
of doctor strange to to be an exact carbon copy
of a comic book villain i know everybody wanted
to see some mephisto easter eggs on the series too
but just because they didn't do him on Wandavision
doesn't mean that they'll never do that character
any stories that they wind up getting rid of or
things they leave on the cutting room floor they
always wind up circling back around too eventually
number two per kevin feige's explanation back
at comic con 2019 it seems like it's been eons
since the last comic-con doctor strange is the
path to the supernatural marvel characters like
blade there are rumors right now that marvel is
going to start filming that mahershala ali blade
movie later this year so part of doctor strange
2 will also probably help set that up i'm not
expecting a huge blade cameo or anything like
that just more explanations for how vampires and
other supernatural creatures exist in the mcu the
moon knight series will also explain some of that
too that's supposed to feature a character called
werewolf by night which goes hand in hand
with explaining vampires and other creatures
right now the moon knight series is supposed
to be released sometime next spring or summer
2022 we'll get more details about that when they
start filming which is actually really soon they
actually just confirmed that ethan hawke is going
to be playing the main villain of that series who
might wind up being a version of mcu dracula we'll
see they haven't confirmed who the main villain
is it's just that dracula is a big character in
those comics i cannot wait till moon night drops
there's going to be so many crazy memes around
that series but number one big one here during
doctor strange two per that setup with billy and
tommy's voices crying for help in the Wandavision
post credit scene they'll pay off wanda's arc by
saving billy and tommy and fully bringing them
back into the main mcu universe but they'll do the
comic book wiccan and speed story and when they
come back they'll come back as teenage versions
of themselves they did have the ability to make
themselves grow older on the fly so they could
either do it that way or they could just say time
moved differently in the chaos realm or whichever
dimension their souls are trapped when wand and
dr strange wind up saving them but they're going
to be a core part of the plot of doctor strange
2 their wanda's whole motivation talking more
about spider-man 3 connections in easter eggs too
on the set of spider-man 3 a while ago when they
were filming there were a lot of easter eggs for
the snap avengers end game avengers infinity
war but there's also a lot of talk about
missing children so the whole missing children's
storyline could have something to do with what's
happening with Wandavision but after doctor
strange 2 wanda will continue to come back
in future marvel movies like avengers 5 maybe more
supernatural movie crossovers cameo scenes here or
there and including the newly rebooted x-men movie
franchise when they eventually get to those films
but also as we all believe pretty easy prediction
to make billy and tommy the teenage versions of
the characters will cross over with other young
avengers characters eventually i've already
talked a lot about the other young avengers
characters that they're setting up in the other
disney plus series but as we get new episodes
of the series i'll point those characters out
they haven't really said but it's always possible
that they do young avengers as a disney plus
series instead of doing it as a straight up mcu
movie but everyone post all your predictions
for the doctor strange 2 movie this really
only scratches the surface i'm hoping to see
a whole bunch of classic spider-man toby maguire
easter eggs too just because it's sam raimi doing
the movie there was even a doctor strange easter
egg during spider-man 2 so you could say there's
a version of that character that exists in the
universe that toby maguire's spider-man comes from
what are we going to call this guy uh uh dr
octopus that's crap science squid crap doctor
strange that's pretty good but it's taken i'm
sure whatever they wind up doing with that movie
is going to be fantastic but i've got a few more
wanda vision videos that i'm working on and new
falcon and winter soldier episodes are going to
start in a couple weeks so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of my episodes for that everyone click here
for my full Wandavision episode 9 finale video in
easter eggs and click here for that Wandavision
post credits scene thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!